bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors à partir à 2 ce
lundi les modèles de masque en tissu
vont être vendus dans les grandes
enseignes les pharmaciens dénoncent un
scandale les ordres à des professions de
santé s'indigne dans une tribune et
votre action vous écoutez cela fait un
mois et demi qu'on court après les
masques
ça a été le le western du masque les on
a réussi à avoir des basques par par les
conseils généraux par les entreprises
aujourd'hui encore on a des
professionnels de santé qui n'ont pas
des masques notamment ffp2 pour
travailler et on s'aperçoit que la
grande distribution et en a accumulé
enfin il ya deux cents ans plus de 200
millions de masques et en commande
encore et qu'ils sont prêts à être
livrés lundi est en vente
donc ça veut donc dire que ces masses
qui les ont depuis un moment puisqu'il a
fallu les répartir parlons de 10 et donc
à partir de là on a quand même un grand
problème dans ce pays on a l'impression
quand même qu' il ya une bataille entre
le ministère de bercy et le ministère de
la santé
sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
toujours toujours en pénurie quand même
et donc et donc qu'on ne peut être que
dégoûter les communiqués de presse que
vous avez cités donc montre bien que les
professionnels de santé aujourd'hui en
ont un petit peu ras-le-bol de cette
situation
comment vous expliquez cette abondance
en face à l'insuffisance des stocks dans
les hôpitaux je parle de l'abondance des
masques qui vont vous être qu'ils vont
être mis en vente à partir de lundi et
dans les grandes surfaces ce que tout le
monde ne sait pas c'est qu'à partir de
50 millions de masques ces stocks
peuvent être réquisitionnés
or là manifestement ce n'a pas été le
cas nous avons des conseils et des cas
des conseils généraux notamment en grand
est et quand il y avait commandé des
masques ces masques ont été
réquisitionnés à l'époque donc on ne
comprend pas pourquoi aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne peut pas réquisitionné
ces masques au profit des soignants qui
n'ont pas assez aujourd'hui la
fédération du commerce et de la
distribution défend les grandes
enseignes en affirmant qu'il n'y a pas
de stock caché qu'en pensez vous le
problème c'est qu'ils ont bien des
stocks puisqu'il a fallu les
reconditionner donc
à partir de là donc par perlot de 10
notamment donc il faut quand même du
temps pour le faire donc ça veut dire
donc attendu grande distribution à
passer ses commandes il ya déjà un grand
moment et que ces stocks sont arrivés
dans les deux trois semaines
antécédentes donc ça veut donc dire
quand même que quelques percées masques
sont en france quelque part et que les
soignants n'ont pas aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile d'avoir des masques les
pharmacies ne sont pas encore toutes
achalandé et c'est vrai que selon les
régions
on a des professionnels qui n'ont pas de
masque aujourd'hui au total 1 500
millions de masques vont être vendus
dans les grandes surfaces dans les
semaines à venir
on a l'impression que les polémiques
elle se suivent en ce qui concerne les
masques et d'abord eu cette pénurie au
tout début de l'épidémie en france et
puis maintenant ce qui va se passer à
partir de lundi dans les grandes
surfaces le le fait que les personnels
de médecins montent au créneau comment
vous expliquer toutes ces polémiques qui
se suivent
quel regard vous portez sur la gestion
de la crise par le gouvernement
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure on
était dans le far west du masque donc
les pharmacies je rappelle que les
pharmacies n'avez pas le droit de les
vendre ou aux gens et donc à partir de
là si je sais les pharmaciens se sont
fait agresser au niveau des masques une
fois en leur disant quand une autre fois
on change la donne quasiment toutes les
toutes les semaines voir tous les quinze
jours on a en a une visibilité sur le
traitement des masques qui est quand
même très floue aujourd'hui et on voit
bien qu'on a un train de retard depuis
le départ que la france n'était pas du
tout ou presque est point pays qui se
veut le cinquième la cinquième puissance
du monde avec un des meilleurs systèmes
de santé
on en est loin aujourd'hui donc et on
voit ce qui s'est passé il faudra quand
même en tirer les leçons très
sérieusement après la crise et puis à le
coup aussi des masques les inégalités
qui vont apparaître aussi parce que tout
le monde n'aura pas les moyens d'acheter
à des masques surtout les familles
nombreuses
alors vous savez j'ai des amis
pharmaciens avec et en discuter sur ces
problèmes là et ils sont vraiment ulcéré
aujourd'hui par contre il donc on met un
prix de vente à 0 95 euro le masque et
moi c'est ami pharmacien me disent mais
nous on les achète à 1,08 aujourd'hui
donc il faut m'expliquer comment on va
faire
donc il ya quand même quand même un
problème de visibilité sur
l'approvisionnement et
vente de ces masques merci beaucoup à
vous philippe vermeil pour avoir répondu
en direct à vos questions sur l'art
tesfran je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du syndicat des médecins
libéraux merci à vous on regarde